contre également vainqueur de la saison
84e éliminé au retour des héros à
l'époque elle avait été un petit peu
dragouiller par notre mode ni regarder
pour que chris télé c'est une très belle
femme et peut pas rester indifférent à
cinq ans
des bleus ou plein de voeux aura
toujours des belges en face à mon dieu
l'homme qui avec toi d'être juste elle
c'est un vrai coup de coeur soit ont
fait pas mal de choses ensemble mais on
dira c'est quelqu'un de très bien il est
très posé très réfléchi très intelligent
très attentionné aussi donc c'est vrai
que je trouve à l'épaule de lumière pour
m'appuyer je pensais à venir avec un
esprit de fargues et finalement je
repars avec un coeur de roméo qui
n'avait pas froid aux yeux qu'elle cache
ce que ça s'est déjà fait chaud dans koh
lanta où je parle de ça comme ça qu'on
est là parce que je vois tout ce que
vous donnez nous des infos sur koh lanta
est ce que c'est la vérité si elle
alors je vous le jure les yeux dans les
yeux sur content il se passe rien mais
ça dit jm non mais c'est la vérité bons
mots si tu le regardes pas simple
l'homme est il au juste
il a perdu tengoku quoi maintenant sur
koh lanta ça s'est déjà fait chaud voilà
ma bonne saison alors mais non mais dans
ta saison il y avait ce ciel chez de
l'onanisme foule alors là on n'est pas
d'accord mais bon moi tout ça ça s'est
déjà fait chaud ah ouais mais nous
apprennons je n'aime pas de mon nom mais
dans les monnaies qui voit là je sais je
sais j'en ai peut-être chasse et la
pêche aux autres saisons mais sur sa
saison ses cousins pour te vient d'en
dans koh lanta il te donne une boîte de
préservatifs à c'est là où la justice
et bah ouais bah je sais pas on n'est
pas d'accord et moi partons pas dans une
boîte de préservatifs
si si si mais en fait ça m'a quand même
voilà attends moi pour ses pas pour
aller voir et je peux vous dire que bon
j'ai un peu voilà quand je suis pas le
dernier pour et de là bas jamais ses
montées et pas le dernier pour calmer là
bas c'est vrai tous 0 ouais au haut
débit direct et tout le temps des sans
quoi ouais voilà non mais ça mon père
mais pas une seule fois en 23 jours non
c'est vrai nom cyrill square est pareil
à vraiment la basse et la batterie
moi j'ai pas dit si on va faire un très
beau pays malheureusement j'ai tout près
de moi même
est ce une vraie révélation dans koh
lanta sa special on le sait nous entrons
peu entre nous qui avait choqué à
montréal et qui a pu choquer ni ce qui
empêche les doigts je te donnerai pas de
blancs arrêtées dont plusieurs saisons
des gens qu'on connaît ce sont les
sondes sur l'hydraulique et le lendemain
sur les épreuves ils sont morts ko naing
ouais tu vois que se sont échauffés
jeudi pages il impose son jeu pas faute
momo dans la merde il a encore espoir de
faire confiance
c'est mon écharpe